- [Ila] The film business
loves to put people in boxes.
You gotta play someone
who just had a car crash,
because you're in a wheelchair.
Here it's like, you don't have that.
- [Peter] The dream is to change the way
disability is seen in America.
There's so much talent and
you see it here with this crew.
- I'm Ila Halby, and I'm one of the
directors at Zeno Mountain Farm.
- Hi, I'm Peter Halby,
another director at Zeno.
Our mission is to support
lifelong friendship
and opportunity for people
with or without disabilities.
It's important for us
to have the integration.
- [Ila] We've run camps all year long.
- And right now, we're at our film camp.
We've been making movies for about 12 years now,
we've done all different types of genres
from a sports drama movie,
we did a time travel movie,
we did a superheroes movie, a western
and this year, we're doing
a high school musical.
- Alright, let's roll camera.
- The last film we did,
we went to film festivals
all over and the hope is that
we get to do that with this.
Every aspect of this film,
we have disabled talent
from the casting to the
lighting, to the script-writing.
- Hi, I'm Alec Bandler.
- Bill James.
- Andrew Pilkington.
- Debbie Beidl.
- Noah Lelchook.
- I'm an actor.
I love being in movies.
- [Ila] We have two really
exciting leads for this movie.
Ricky and Roxy.
- Go for Roxy.
- Hi, my name is Ricky Wilson Jr
and I'm playing Tony Michaels.
- Hi, my name is Roxanne
Schiebergen and I'm playing Sage.
- You guys ready?
Let's roll the music.
- The film is basically
about two teenagers
who go to summer camp
and they fall in love.
- It's sort of an homage
to a lot of the classics
such as, Grease, Footloose.
- All the disability just fades away here
and everyone's just a person.
In the outside film world, disability
has to be written in the story.
People have to know why.
My character, Sage,
it's never discussed why
she's in a wheelchair and
I think that's so awesome.
- Yeah, it's incredible.
- Everyone's just beaming, constantly.
This is their lives, they live for Zeno
and you can feel it when you're here.
- In the disability world, there’s, there’s this
isolation, there's this lack
of opportunity that exists.
At Zeno, everyone understands each other,
wants to connect and to
find the talent in everyone.